The other question that we had were just on lifestyle questions, and we go back to this chart, and I told my staff that sometimes I think, oh, I've already shared about this thing, so I don't want to share about it again.
But I forget that not everybody thinks the same way I do and thinks about these things 24 seven.
So I need to hit some of these things again. So lifestyle factors that affect this pathway, this pathway, this mTOR pathway is critically important with those that have cancer.
So we do not want to stimulate or excessively stimulate, you can't help but stimulate the mTOR pathway.
That's how your body heals, but we don't want to add any extra burden of stimulation to our mTOR pathway.
And the mTOR pathway is a genetic pathway that creates an enzyme that stimulates healing.
So what the mTOR does, you look at follow the arrows, it stimulates messenger RNA translations, which is how your cells replicate, and how we don't want to do that with cancer patients, right?
It stimulates aerobic glycolysis, which that's what most cancers are already feeding off of is aerobic glycolysis.
That's the best way in order to make energy is aerobic glycolysis.
Well, we don't want to stimulate that in a cancer patient.
It stimulates lipid synthesis and fatty acid cycle pathway, energy production, pentose, phosphate pathway, that's energy production as well, nucleotide synthesis, that's how you replicate cells.
So these are all great things to have if we're growing. These are great things to have if I'm trying to build muscle, if I'm going for a workout and I want to get stronger and build muscle, if I'm healing from an injury, if I'm growing as a child, these are all things that you want to take place.
That's why I said multiple places that if I'm dealing with a heart condition and I want you to tissue to grow that I want to stimulate mTOR function.
If I'm dealing with trying to stay anti-aging protocol for a patient, I want to stimulate mTOR function.
If I'm dealing with cancer, it's a totally different ball game. We don't want to stimulate mTOR function in that cancer.
So the way we would treat some diseases is very different than the way we want to treat a cancer patient.
So in a cancer patient, we don't want to stimulate mTOR function.
All these things in the green here are things that stimulate mTOR function. Now, if you start thinking through these, they make a lot of sense.
So, amino acids, so I eat a lot of amino acids, it stimulates mTOR function. That's what a body builder would do.
We're going to eat a lot of meat, we're going to eat a lot of proteins because we're want to build muscles.
Hormone function, so when what our body goes through and build up of hormones, we stimulate mTOR and our body starts changing.
IGF1 function has to do with healing injuries and healing wounds, also has to do with a young person growing.
So in childhood, we have a high IGF1 function, it stimulates mTOR. We eat sugar, we stimulate insulin production by the pancreas, we stimulate mTOR.
We increase iron in our diet, we stimulate mTOR. That's why iron may not be a good idea for most cancer patients.
Society, which is an amino acid, again, and SAME, which these are very important to the methionine cycle when we look at your genetics, but too much of it stimulates mTOR.
Glutamates, we have done that on a weekly basis, I do at least, because it's the number one thing that stimulates mTOR.
Using folate, I get this all the time, and we need to have a discussion maybe next week, just on that, because there's a giant fad today about the MTHFR gene.
So the MTHFR gene, there's even Facebook groups of MTHFR Facebook group, and I can't even look at the post because I used to post on there and tell people the truth that I just got tired, I feel like I was begging my head against the wall.
But there's people absolutely completely obsessed with the MTHFR gene, and it's mainly because of practitioners that are giving very, very false information.
So sometimes it's dangerous when you know just a little bit about something.
So I have a lot of patients that are taking a lot of folate, or a methyl tetrahydrofolate product, or any methylated B12 methyl comolomy, that will stimulate mTOR.
So we got to be careful on how much we use of that, a little bit for a cancer patient could be just fine.
Too much, we can really stimulate mTOR.
The cytokines, this what happens, the cytokine is a type of chemical that's made by the immune system in the, in place of a chronic infection, usually a person has a ramped up TH1 cytokines in a chronic infection and stimulates mTOR.
So that's why biotoxins, some clinical, long-term, some clinical media, not really symptomatic chronic infection like H. Pylori, or even Lyme disease can be a major cause for cancer.
So mTOR genes themselves, so there's different genes that we look at your genes that are what are called mTOR genes because they actually having those genes, those defects actually can stimulate cancer.
So when these were first discovered, they thought they found the cause of cancer, but they found, now it's known that oncogenes are the cause of cancer, but they're just another piece that can stimulate mTOR, that can increase the rate of cancer replication if you have cancer.
So these in themselves are necessarily causes of cancer, these are participants in an increasing rate of cancer growth in a person that has cancer, so that's the important thing to look at.
So that's why we take people on a limited area and limit their protein consumption, stay away from plastic, stay away from cell phone towers at EMFs and look at that, no high fructose cancer, no higher-ded-rich foods, no methyl products, glutamate, glutamate, MSG, bone broth, pesticides.
So that's why I do make these recommendations, and it's good to how does this once in a while, because sometimes we forget that we start slacking on our diet and everything, and that's not a good thing, but if you know why you're doing something, it could give you some ammunition to stay the course.